um
[Music]
did i ever tell you why i left scranton
yeah i didn't think i had
well
it was all about pam
yeah i mean
she was with roy
and uh
i just couldn't take it
i mean i lost it dwight
i couldn't sleep
i couldn't concentrate on anything
and then weird stuff like
food
had no taste
so my solution was to move away
it was awful
and it is something that i wouldn't wish
on my worst enemy
and that includes you
dwight's about to get fired you have to
tell him
just get the words out that's all you
can do okay
all right
showtime
dwight you again gosh i keep throwing
you away you keep flying back you're
like an amish return stick okay great
listen to me listen to me no no no i
know will you just let me tell you one
thing please yes you may tell me one
thing great wait do you want to borrow
money listen to me robert is going to
veto the saber store jim come on dwight
he's going to kill the store and then
i'm pretty sure he's gonna fire you for
it
wait he's gonna kill the store
and he's gonna fire me yes
that's two things dwight please nice try
jim your pranks have never worked in the
past and they're not gonna work today
okay first of all they've mostly worked
you know what you might want to get to
the airport it's going to take you a
long time to get through security with
all those beauty products bye
dwight come on
nothing is going to stop me that is the
mark of a great man unstoppability
dunder mifflin
farm moe's all those things
vanish in my rear-view mirror
now if you'll excuse me
i have a date with destiny and from what
i hear she's a spoof
oh of course don't lick my hand
god why is there so much saliva all i
had to do was think about pie my
salivary glands did the rest gross
oh my god
oh my appendix i'm sorry my wound hasn't
started yet i'm sorry oh man i'm so
sorry i forgot you all right
you okay
what do we got
i was thinking of proposing to esther
today
wow okay congratulations that's a really
big step she's got a ton of great
qualities she's young she's beautiful
jean's so pure you could lick them
her family admires me my family
tolerates hers a lot of them are the
same people because we're third cousins
which is great for bloodlines and isn't
technically incest right in the sweet
spot i think you're gonna be really
happy plus her dowry contains a walk-in
freezer full of frozen premium cattle
sperm
that's a lot of pros and did i mention
that she weaves colorful durable
blankets and rugs it all adds up
so what is the problem
angela
all i know is that
every time i've been faced with a tough
decision
there's only
one thing that outweighs every other
concern
one thing that will make you give up on
everything you thought you knew
every instinct
every
rational calculation
some sort of virus
love
oh
dwight listen
no matter what happens
you gotta forget about all the other
stuff you gotta forget about logic
and fear
and doubt
you just gotta do everything you can
to get to the one woman who's gonna make
all this worth
at the end of the day
[Music]
you gotta jump
[Music]
you love angela dwight
i think you always have
you're a good assistant jim
not as good as you
that's very true
get the hell out of here you got it
what are you doing well i'm just trying
to go get up okay okay get up all right
i'm not gonna let you buy then you know
what i'm gonna just have to run right
through you okay
what are you doing
are you really revving up you know that
doesn't work
jackie chan
oh what are you doing no no no no no no
end this is down this ram
[Applause]
anything else you need to talk about
no
that was it
once again
it's showtime
what baffles me is how you could take a
perfectly good idea which the great joe
bennett rightfully signed off on and
then utterly botch it in execution
i can't get fired i'm an institution i
have been at this company for 20 years
how many of you have been here that long
huh
j p and d the three amigos uh warms my
heart hey what do you say when i get
back from our honeymoon the three of us
have a conference room meeting just for
fun
what is that meaningful look
you know what maybe we should talk
i finally feel ready
athlete is growing asleep and jim can
jump back in without skipping a beat
we'll come back to visit but i think
it's time for us to officially no don't
say it you're fired you're both fired
dwight come on don't end on a bad note
don't be an idiot it's for the severance
the best that i can do is one month for
every year you've been here that's the
max
thanks dwight
hey and if you're ever in austin oh
right for what the art the music the
incredible nightlife no thank you but if
you're ever in the area you'll always
have a place to stay
in my barn
there it is
all right
now i think it's time for you to go what
oh jim
i thought we talked about this you're
cool right kathy go
where's the bug awesome
stand back
what is that it's a compound of
chemicals i pulled off of the maids cart
right there
oh god stop it stop it oh big one big
one i think i saw it i think i saw it
nice job i think you got him
you can't stay here this place is a
biohazard
very i just bunk with kathy
second best bananas foster i've ever had
well what's the first best
two nights ago dwight
hello
twice
are you in there
i can see the light on under your door
hello
oh look at that the light went off just
as i said the light went off
hello
dwight
oh
dwight
you ready
you kidding
i was born
[Music]
wait wait ready
um
i don't know how to tell you this but
we have a little bit of a problem
you know what
the minister just told me that it's
tradition for the bestish mensch to be
older than the groom
oh come on i've never heard of said i
haven't heard of it obviously
but i'm out because i'm significantly
younger than you not significant as a
big word i think you're well okay either
way either way dwight
i can't be there for you
i'm sorry
jim
i just
really wish there was something i could
do
michael
i can't believe you came
that's what you said
[Laughter]
best prank ever
you